right games has issued an update on a
pretty serious Cyber attack that they
dealt with last week their original post
from January 20th says earlier this week
systems in our development environment
were compromised by a social engineering
attack we don't have all the answers
right now but we wanted to communicate
early and let you know there is no
indication that Playa data or personal
information was obtained a tweet today
from the riot games Twitter account says
as promised we wanted to update you on
the status of last week's Cyber attack
over the weekend our analysis confirmed
source code for League TFT and a legacy
anti-cheat platform were exfiltrated by
the attackers which is pretty major
stuff they continued today we received a
ransom email needless to say we won't
pay while this attack disrupted our
build environment and could cause issues
in the future most importantly we remain
confident that no player data or
personal information was compromised